hey everyone it's Sarah with registered
nurse rn.com and in this video I want to
demonstrate how to take an ovulation
test ovulation tests are very helpful
because they can help you track your
most fertile days so that can help you
determine whenever you're actually
ovulating and ovulation is a process
where your ovaries release an egg and an
egg needs to be released and fertilized
by a sperm so you can get pregnant and
how ovulation tests work is that they
detect the luteinizing hormone surge
which is known as the LH surge and this
happens every month to prepare your
ovaries so they'll release an egg and
the LH surge can really vary from month
to month when it actually happens so
it's important that you track that LH
surge so you can increase your chances
of conceiving and this hormone surge is
actually occurring about 24 to 36 hours
before an ovary actually releases an egg
so you want to make sure once you get
that positive result that you have
sexual intercourse within the next 48
hours now in addition to this positive
ovulation test we're result there are
other indicators that might tell you
that you're ovulating such as clear
stretchy cervical mucus which is similar
to the consistency of an egg white also
your libido will likely be highest
during this period so you might find
that you're more interested in physical
intimacy around this time so now let me
demonstrate how to take an ovulation
test and for this test I'm going to be
using the clear blue digital ovulation
test first you need to determine your
menstrual cycle link because this will
help you determine when you need to
start testing to do this you'll want to
determine the dates of when your last
period started the Period start date is
known as cycle day one and you're going
to want to kill until the day before
your next period begins it's best to use
at least three months of cycles and
average them out you can then determine
your average cycle length if you need
more information on calculating your
menstrual cycle length I have a video
that you can watch that will help you do
that once you know your cycle link your
ovulation test kit will have a chart to
tell you which cycle day you need to
start testing for example if your cycle
was 29 days long you'd want to start
testing on cycle day 12. now if you
don't know your cycle length this brand
Clearblue actually recommends starting
on cycle day 10. and Clearblue suggests
using it at least four hours after
urinating and you can take it any time
of the day as long as you use it at the
same time each day now when you're ready
to collect your urine sample on the day
of your test I found that it's easiest
to collect the urine in a cup then you
want to open the test strip package and
find the Pink Arrow on the test strip
and align it with the test holders Pink
Arrow then insert until you hear a
clicked and prepare the test by removing
the pink cap you'll know it's ready when
the test ready symbol appears on the
screen now you're ready to dip it into
your urine sample immediately dip the
absorbent tip only into the urine for 15
seconds then we're going to remove the
test from the urine put the cap back on
and place it on a flat surface as we
await the results and the display will
flash as it's reading the results just
to let you know that everything is
working and around after about three
minutes the test will be complete so if
no LH surge is detected you'll see a
blank Circle in this case you should
keep on testing each day at the same
time now if the smiley face appears it
means the LH surge was detected and you
should have sexual intercourse within
the next 48 hours to increase your odds
of pregnancy once you get the smiley
face you can stop testing for the rest
of your cycle and after you're done
reading the results eject the test strip
by hitting the eject button and discard
it and keep that test holder for other
tests that you take okay so that wraps
up this video on how to use an ovulation
test if you'd like to watch more videos
on pregnancy you can access the videos
in the YouTube description below